Welcome to the show, Frank. Please take a
moment to tell us a little bit more
about you and what you've been up to
lately.
Cool. Thanks thanks, David, for having me on,
first of all.
Well, for everybody out there, I'm Frank. I'm
a currently a staff engineer at Personio, which
is a big HR company based out of
Germany.
I joined
Personio
about
a year ago. Before that, I did a
couple years in in fintech, which
gave me a lot of appreciation
for the sort of more consistent side of
things. Like,
losing a transaction is not something that fintech
really
really accepts. So
especially in sort of
larger distributed systems
with many systems integrating
often with events
and messages,
that was a really interesting
experience.
Before that, I did a lot of work
for
Circle, the airports here nearby.
I did a fully event driven real time
dashboard
application for their internal
operation
with highly sensitive data.
That was in TypeScript. And for the rest,
I've done a lot of stuff in in
PHP.
My current day job is more with Kotlin.
So for me, like, languages or
whatever.
And so I've been doing this for a
while now. Think, like, I'm close
to fifteen years of of doing this stuff.
So yeah. And I'm looking forward to doing
it at least fifteen years more.
Yeah. Awesome. Alright. Thank you for sharing. So,
yeah, I I kinda you know, I've followed
you for a while with Tati before in
the past, and I knew you from the
PHP ecosystem, but I did see that you
were doing Java and Kotlin and TypeScript as
well. Like,
it's I think it's always interesting that the
more we do this, the more the language
becomes less important. Right? And it's more about
all the things you'd learn
along the way. So, hopefully, we'll we'll get
into that in more detail as we go
through the episodes. Yeah. I, I totally agree.
Right? So you see, all of things sort
of lumping together and doesn't at the end,
it doesn't really matter what tool we use
anymore. But it also means that you're gonna
encounter the same problems in just in in
different flavors.
Yeah.
Yeah. Or rewrite the same library 14 times
on other languages that you're gonna work with.
Wow.
Like,
I have written or rewritten
EventSauce,
which is an open source library that I
maintain.
I've rewritten that in a couple of languages
now, which is always an interesting experience because
while the majority of the things that you
do sort of maintain or they are the
same, but some things you really adjust towards
what's kind of language mechanics you have. And
that's always an interesting
routes to explore when whenever I'm doing that
in a new language.
Yeah. I mean, I I I don't have
the first question. I'll pan out, but I'm
gonna skip it right now. It's go down
this little path where we're talking because
one of the things I found most important
in my career, and I think you just
kind of alluded to it there as well,
is that when I wrote c, I learned
how to write c code. When I did
PHP, learned how to write PHP code. When
I did Alexa, I learned how to write
Alexa code and so forth and so forth.
Right? Go and Rust, like I love experimenting
with languages.
But what I love more is learning from
the idiomatics
of each language. Like, concurrency and Go is
very different from what I've done in PHP.
Concurrency and Alexa is very different to Go
as well because it has this actor based
process model. And, like, it's just through the
combination of all of these different
idiosyncrasies,
I don't even know if that's the right
word, of each of these languages and runtimes.
But you build up a different picture of
what software should look like in your head
regardless of the language. Like, I don't think
I would be the developer I am today
if I hadn't worked in all of those
languages and learned all of the different things
they do different in their ecosystem.
Does that make sense?
Absolutely. Like, one of the first, conference talks
that I ever
did was at Lericon,
I think, in, like, when was this? 02/2012
or something like that? And it was a
talk called the knowledge of others. And it
was basically a talk about looking at various
ways of solving a problem.
And during the talk, I sort of looked
at different types
of problems and then looked at what languages
are
most
likely to solve that's that's that problem.
So for example, like in in JavaScript, you
have a lot of sort of in process
events driven
stuff. So I looked at like, hey, what's
what does an event
emitter dispatcher
look like in in JavaScript and how can
we sort of get the same kind kind
of capabilities in, for example, a a language
like PHP
and also what's missing or what's not fitting
very well and how can you overcome that?
Like, I think that's a very
interesting way of looking at it. But you
you look at these languages and how they
frame it and the idiomatic
solutions
always provide a certain type of framing. Right?
So for for Go, like you mentioned Go,
I think the the model of concurrency there
is is very interesting to to to look
at and it's very like or the way
that I did it at least was very
channel based. Right? This is what's go, the
programming language where it really promotes and they've
got a very strong sense of how you
should route write code like that. And using
stuff like that in like, trying to replicate
that in in different languages is
sort of an interesting exercise.
It doesn't always play out, but you can
definitely take some learnings from one idiomatic approach
and apply it in a different different space.
If anything, it's a lot of fun. Yes.
I will 100% agree with that. And I
have taken a note about the knowledge of
others LaraCon talk. So I'll make sure there's
a link to that in the show notes
so that I can find that online for
people to to check it. I was like,
I don't wanna watch it myself. So
Well, I I don't think it's probably not
my my best, talk ever. Like, I think
it was one of the first talks that
I ever did in public, and I actually
don't remember a lot of it because, like,
being on stage, especially that point was, like,
such a sort of high intensity, high stress
moments that, you know, my brain blocked to
mature.
So mind you, the quality might be not
what you expect it to be. Awesome. Alright.
Let's go back to the planned first question
then. So, obviously, we've discussed event sourcing.
Before, you've already mentioned event source, your library,
you've now written it in multiple languages,
and it's a great way for people to
get started with event sourcing. But what I
want to understand is how did you even
end up in this event driven architecture ecosystem?
How what led you from writing,
you know, your your PSP and just writing
web apps or whatever it was you were
doing back in the day to go, crap.
Like, I want everything to be event driven.
What was the path like for you there?
Well, so, I was very fortunate enough to
work on a couple of projects where this
was just
needed. Like, the only way to do things
was an event driven way.
The first
project where it was really relevant was the
website for Schiphol.
So that was still in sort of the
website y
area, but it it got a little bit
more complex with some some logic there. But
effectively, the way that we had to ingest
flight information needed to be as close to
real time as possible. Right? So as soon
as possible, view on what the planes were
doing.
As a customer, you wanted to know like,
hey, I'm going on a KLM flight and
I'm going to London. What's the status of
the of the flight?
I want to, in my web app, follow
that flights, keep keep track of it. And
whenever something new is up, I would want
to see that. Now
the only real way to do that for
the scale that we were at, like, doing
that for all of the passengers
that go through simple,
you can't do that on a polling basis
and then figure out the delta between all
of the flights that are there everywhere. Right?
So one, it's it's it's not efficient enough,
but that's also not quick enough. Right? You
want it as soon as it's as it
happens.
So we built a a whole event based
integration
there and that was really on the consuming
side of an event stream. So I I
would say that's a relatively
comfortable way of starting out in the events
driven space
is to be a consumer of events.
Right? So you can sort of skip the
whole how,
when, and in what form should I be
producing this and just see it as a
stream of information
that you can respond to, that you can
create projections
from and all that. So that was my
sort of initial
introduction into the event driven space, which was
soon followed by going into the event sourced
space. For this same airport, we created a
way to book parking spots for Schiphol which
for an airport is a huge revenue stream.
And so it's being a huge revenue stream.
You also want to get a high level
of insight into what is going on and
why things are going the way they are.
So for example, if you're booking parking spots,
you get multiple
types of parking spots made available for you
which are at different price ranges.
So you also want to know as a
vendor of these parking spots,
like what does the positioning of those parking
spots do for the general choice of the
parking spots afterwards. Right? So you can do
this with just
an API call and record the response, then
track where you positioned it, and then do
a separate call afterwards to say, hey, which
one
was picked?
But it's very indirect. And a more direct
way is to just record that all of
as events and then make sure that you
use those events to gain those insights along
the way. There I was very fortunate to
work with Marine Heisenfeldt
who was doing event sourcing, like, I think
maybe even before I started programming.
So I had a very, like a veteran
of event sourcing
as a mentor and as somebody who guided
that entire project. So I was very much
in a following capacity when I was executing
that and Marine was really leading that effort
there. Nice.
Well, yeah. I I I got a couple
of questions. Right? So you can imagine event
driven and then event sourcing.
And, you know, to the people that are
listening, I'm gonna ask you very the same
question twice, but for each of those. And
you can just say yes or no. You
can give more information if you want. Right?
But would you say that
most applications could benefit
from adopting some event driven aspects?
Yes. Alright. What about event sourcing? Is this
what the question I'm really getting at here
is what is the decision? What what thought
process do people need to make before they
say, I'm gonna bring event sourcing into my
application? Can they do it for all applications
or is it a very specific requirement need?
How how do you make that decision? Yeah.
For me, it needs to be the core
core business that you're that you're modeling.
And there needs to be a
like, I like it when there is a
temporal
effect to it. So multiple things happening
after each other. There's a sequence to it.
And what
happens
is sometimes as interesting as the state that
you end up with. So if you compare
it to CRUD applications, right, CRUD applications, you
have a state, something happens, you overwrite something,
you have a new state, you overwrite the
past effectively. This also means that you lose
that state. Right? So you forget about the
past, but you also forget the delta. With
event sourcing,
you store everything that happens as a general
principle
as events and then you just append those
events. So this also means that you retain
all of the information over time, but you
also retain all of the delta. In fact,
the thing that you retain is the delta.
So you're always able to get from where
you were to where you are now.
And there are a couple of benefits to
that, which some problems are more prone to
benefits from than others.
So for example, if you have changing policies
and those policies need to be applied even
though something
was vetted through the process before and was
deemed okay.
Now a new policy is added, things no
longer valid.
How do you deal with that? Right? Having
that stream of events and not just the
outcome of something is valid, yes or no,
right, is useful in in such a case.
If you're doing something that's purely crud, right,
I need to get an inventory
or I need to have
what is it? A user management, all of
those things probably not useful because you're you're
only
interested in really the current state of things.
Like how how things got there, you don't
really care about it. Permission management, right, you
don't care about how the permissions got to
the state where they were, but you care
about what your current permissions are and how
to apply them. So not all problem areas
really benefit from. You got to understand
your domain to the point where you understand
there's value and those missing pieces of information
that we purge with a standard current based
operating system. I kind of understand that. Right?
Yeah. But then by saying that we wouldn't
adopt event sourcing for a current application,
I think what the subtext is saying there
is that there's a cost of adopting event
sourcing within your organization. Yeah. And so it's
it's not
always just four lanes of code and I've
got an event sourced application anymore. So I'll
come at this from two different angles then.
It's like, what what is the cost? Why
is it challenging for people to bring event
sourcing into an application to their team, to
their organization?
And part two of that as well, what
is it our future where event sourcing becomes
more of a commodity where it's easier to
bring into a project without that cost? Yeah.
So there's definitely a cost to it. I
would argue that the cost is mostly misinterpreted
or misassigned.
The biggest cost is probably that on people.
So if you're looking at experience for crowd
based application development, it's there in abundance.
If you're looking at the experience in building
event driven architectures,
there are still plenty, but it's a lot
fewer than,
like, finding people who can build good crop
applications
Where people usually attribute the cost of of
event driven architectures
is saying like, hey, now I need a
queue. Now I need all of these background
processes.
Now I need all this orchestration.
And I would just say like that's that's
not inherent to event driven architecture. So you
can do event
sourcing,
which is a very event centric approach of
modeling domains.
You can do that in a single threaded
language like PHP without
a queue. Right? You can do in process
consumers
where the events that you record are passed
in the same web request to the consumers
that project their state, send their emails,
send send out API calls to other kinds
of services.
That's all possible. Is it ideal?
No. But it is a good starting point.
Right? If you have a tiny application
that needs to do need to do a
couple of things, reliability is not yet a
big concern,
then you can really reduce the cost by
turning down all of these levers. Right? You
don't need fully false tolerance,
everything
at the start of a project. Right? So
yeah.
Okay. So let's pivot the question again one
more degree. You've got this team of engineers.
You're on it. Right? You're you're kicking ass.
You built an event driven system before. You've
got event source and 2,000 languages. Anybody can
build event source application nice and easy. Would
you
personally, just you,
if I came across and said, I have
this really simple CRUD based application
or microservice that we need as part of
a larger application.
At that point, is it easier for you
to do it with event sourcing, or is
there still a cost for you to do
it? Like, I'm wondering if, like, if I
have the experience, if we have a team
of experienced people, like, would you default to
event sourcing or would you go just credit
just credit? No. So defaulting
to any type of technology for me always
sounds like a very dogmatic thing to do.
So you need to balance it with,
like, the benefits
of implementing some something and the cost of
it. And so especially when you have a
large team around you, if you
don't have any event driven experience within a
a company, then you're saying like, hey, we're
gonna change this core component and we're gonna
switch it from a more crowd based to
a events driven approach.
I that has a serious expense to it.
So it it's more that the expenses that
you're gonna the organization will need to learn
about event driven architectures and that means that
they're gonna fail at at it for some
time.
And so you need to find a a
mode within the company that they're able to
fail.
And sometimes the expense is
is high, but even even then it can
be okay enough to to to do it.
So for example, in in some systems that
I worked on, all of the adjacent business
processes were taking direct database access,
to the columns that they needed,
to get their information from. Well, this also
meant that it was very difficult to change
that system.
So by introducing events, we allowed the second
secondary business processes to decouple from those internals,
giving the internals the freedom to change. Right?
So because this was a very necessary change
for the system,
the rewards were higher than the cost. Right?
And so in those cases, you can do
that.
But you need to have seen sort of
the other side in order to make that
assessment. And that's sometimes difficult. Right? If you
have decision makers within the same company who
haven't yet seen that that benefits,
then it's hard to sell them based on
the on the claims and the merits of
those those solutions.
Yeah. I love that you mentioned the the
failure aspect there. I think what a lot
of people often forget is that people with
experience or people that are good at
rating Kotlin that doing Kubernetes about a microservices,
doing event sourcing.
They weren't magically good at it because they've
done a lot. They're they're good at it
because they've done it wrong more times than
anyone else. Right? And it's
yeah. Teams have to build up that competency.
And sadly,
fastest way to do it is to get
a lot of shit wrong. So Yeah.
Yeah. Sort of,
like, eat dirt, get up and continue.
Alright. Look. We've chatted for, like, twenty minutes
now,
and we haven't really tackled for anyone who's
new to event source and CQRS and event
driven architectures, I kind of overview. Now we
have covered a little bit of it through
your conversation. You've talked about squashing
or losing history and maintaining history and stuff
like that. But maybe we could give people
a quick five minute overview on
EDA event sourcing and CQRS and how those
work together. Yeah. Alright. I I will start
with with event sourcing.
So
event sourcing is really a way to model
problem domains.
We're using events as the the primitive
to record what's happened with the store states.
In event sourcing specifically,
you also say that the states that you
use in order to base new decisions upon
are
in essence sourced by the events that you
record. And this usually means that you reconstitute
your
domain model by reapplying all of the events
of the past, putting you in a condition
to make a decision
that will then again result
into
a newly recorded event.
This is different from traditional
entity based and state based
modeling
where you overwrite
the past. A
reason why this is was introduced is effectively
for not
losing the history that you have recorded along
the way. It's very inspired by accounting.
If you have a bank account somewhere and
you
deducted too much money somewhere, right, you don't
get that row
adjusted.
You get a counter transaction
that says like, hey, I'm gonna file a
correction now.
So for example, I overbooked some money, removed
120,
but I meant to deduct 100.
Now I'm gonna sort of reimburse you 20.
We all know how this happened and how
we got to the end state. We know
how the correction happens. Well, for some business
processes, this is really important to to have
us as context.
Now that sort of event sourcing in its
in its essence.
So
sometimes it helps to
relate back to other primitives
to sort of see how it really works.
I usually say like, hey, an aggregate which
is what's or an aggregate root which is
what you refer to in event sourcing terms
as as the entity is sort of the
you have a stream of events and you
sort of map reduce
that those events into a state. You use
this state in order to provide the context
for your next decision and then afterwards are
more events and that's what you get out.
The benefit of this is that it becomes
really deterministic.
If you have state based application,
applications,
you need to set the state and whether
that state is something that you would end
up in or not. Right? That's that's out
of the question. And then you need to
make a decision and then new state is
what you actually assert on.
In events driven systems, especially event sourced ones,
you can have a really nice given when
then structure
which says like, given these events, when I
do this action,
now I ex expect these events to be
recorded. And that's very deterministic.
It's almost like mathematical
in that sense.
You can sort of see that as a
proof of the system working without having to
manipulate any inner parts of the system. So
that's that's very nice. So I think does
that sort of clarify the whole event sourcing
part? Yeah. I think that was spot on.
I'm I'm gonna add one example that I
found really useful. I can't remember who it
was. It was either you, Tomi, and the
pub, or maybe it was Greg going on
one of his talks. But it was the
ecommerce example
where
if you think about building an Amazon or
someone adds something to a car and removes
it from the car and they do that
5,000 times and then they buy one item,
there's 5,000 items there that you can upsell
them later if you track that they added
it and removed it from the car. And
that that was the one and I still
remember that example clear as data today.
It's the one when I went, oh, there
is a lot of value in some of
that information that we've always parched
in the past. Yeah. I think one of
the situations that I think is
often underutilized
even in event sourcing
is recording of failure.
So if you if you, for example, want
to pay for something but you have insufficient
budget, right? In a entity based system or
a state based system, right, you say, I'm
I'm entering the methods. Do I have enough
balance? If no, throw exception.
If yes, mutate the states. Only then it
has effect.
Within the event source system, you might say,
into the to
the methods,
see if there is enough balance. If not,
record an event and throw an exception and
you always store any type of events that
you record. So usually you put that in
a try and then finally block where even
if there is an exception, you store all
of the recorded events.
And all of the sudden,
have insights into all of your unhappy parts.
Right? So you can capture the context of
the failure
and that's really like where you see the
users have friction with your product or with
your business process or anything in relation to
that. Nice. Great example. Alright. Let's tackle the
the next one then. So CQRS.
Yeah. So CQRS
like I'm I'm bigger on event sourcing than
I am on CQRS.
So CQRS I often see or when it's
talked about in the community, it's talked about
applying it in a very dogmatic way. And
so you're you have to separate
everything
that's an instruction to the system so that
that tells the system to do something.
And the other part is really how to
get information out. The reason they they want
that is to allow
for different models on how you query that
data which are optimized for querying and the
decision model is not necessarily
the best
model to also query it. So for example,
if you have an order based system and
you want to aggregate how many orders there
were today and what their cumulative
amount was, right, you can do a sort
of SQL aggregation over that. But it might
not be very efficient if you have a
large amount of customers. Right? So using events
to then say like, hey, I'm gonna record
all of the events of the purchases and
then I've got a secondary model, which is
the accumulation of all of the amounts that
were stored for a day. You have a
a sort of a live view of what
that means across the day and querying it
is just basically querying a column within a
database. Right? Very efficient.
And so there's definitely value in separating
out these models,
but always doing that. Right? I think lacks
a bit of nuance in that sense. Right?
For many of the the problems that you
have, the original
decision model has enough
data points that you can use for reads.
And also always doing it, how do you
say this? A lot of people applying
CQRS
also say like, hey, then you put it
on a message bus.
And so that means that the state that
you want to query maybe in the same
request is already eventual consistent.
Right? So then you need to deal with
that fact again.
Well, people create all kinds of ways to
to work around that problem. So one is
like your aggregate
has versioning
and now your projections have versions as well.
You're just gonna pull the the read model
until you get the right version if you
want to get the response for that that
version.
Right? That's a possibility, but it's also very
cumbersome. Right? So you get some dogmatic things
like command buses shouldn't return any,
values and all that shenanigan.
Like those shenanigans, I think it's too dogmatic.
So I think as a pattern, like being
able to separate those things, fine. Always doing
that, I don't really see the value in
that. Okay. Let's touch on one more thing
and then we'll move on with the questions.
But you've covered event sourcing. Great. CQRS.
Perfect. So if we have all of these
events, we have to build projections.
We have message buses.
A lot of what we're seeing here, right,
kinda maps to what I'm seeing in a
different ecosystem, which is cloud native Kubernetes.
Right? We're seeing micro service adoption,
which is being built on event
architectures where people are preferring
to do
publish events to Nats or Kafka, RabbitMQ, etcetera.
And all of these service are independent.
Right? The goal is to be loosely coupled.
And it feels like there's actually a lot
of crossover
and benefits to both of these architectures maybe
working together.
But I'm curious if this is something that
you've seen a lot of from the event
sourcing ecosystem.
Are people doing microservices?
Are projections of microservice? Like, how do these
two different tangential things work together or correlate?
Yeah. And so I think they're just the
same thing at the different scale. Right? So
if you've got a monolithic application
that is recording messages that the that it's
consuming itself in order to record state as
a projection
that it's surfing on a different rest end
point. That's for me the same as two
services which are which there is a dependency
between which where you have a source system
for information and a dependent system and it's
using messages to be kept up to date.
Right? So in essence, it's the same thing
but then scaled up and maybe with a
higher infrastructural cost associated
with it. But in principle, it's it's just
the same. The thing where where deviates
is
in the
coupling and knowledge area.
So if you have two different services,
you know that the services have a different
level of detail regarding a particular subject.
So if you're in a monolithic situation
where you're the consumer of events, you tend
to have a a high level of detail
and a high level of volatility of the
information that you're consuming.
So if you're modeling your business processes with
events, then innovating on that business model means
changing events.
If you're doing that for yourself, you're exposed
to your own volatility. Right? So that means
that you need to if there is a
new version of something, you need to account
for the backwards compatibility at least for the
periods where you're exposed to those changing events.
Now if you amplify this to the microservice
world, this volatility
means usually
that you're gonna be disrupting other services unless
they accommodate for this change as well. And
especially in larger organizations where those
services
are not maintained by the same people, this
is where you get up into Shit Creek
area. Right? So if you're changing the event
stream that somebody else is consuming
and you're not informing them and allowing them
to accommodate this
in in some way, shape, or form, you're
gonna cause a disruption in production.
And so that's more difficult. Now luckily, there
are patterns to deal with it.
But this usually like you asked before like,
hey, what's the cost of introducing event driven
stuff into into projects?
It's learning this and learning the ways to
deal with it. So
in event driven architectures,
usually say like, hey, just expose everything.
Right? So as a first
iteration,
I've got all my internal domain events.
Well, now they're all external domain events and
everybody can listen to everything.
Now I want to change something. I've done
the whole integration part before.
Now I want to change anything.
Now I need to change all of my
integrations.
Right? And so while event driven architecture is
usually attributed that is great for decoupling,
unless you do that on the information level,
you're still just very highly coupled from business
process to business process and you still need
to do sort of diligent information disclosure and
deliberate information disclosure
in order to prevent that. Right? So within
object oriented stuff,
we say, well, we've got an interface and
then you can touch these public things, but
you cannot touch these private things. Right? Within
events or different architectures,
especially if your implementations
mature,
you see the same effects. Right? You've got
internal
information streams,
you've got external
information streams, and you you act differently
With object oriented, you say like, hey, I'm
maintaining sort of a backwards compatibility
for a large degree and sometimes
I'm creating
APIs with a new version. Right?
That same applies to event driven architectures.
But there then you're
accommodating that by versioning the payloads that you
send and then putting anti corruption layers in
place, which are either on the producing end
or on the consuming end that smooth over
the differences between these versions. So that means,
so for example, if you are producing
a new version of your event
which has
more fields or fields that are just formatted
a little bit different,
something that's really backwards incompatible,
then what you can do is have sort
of a mechanism on the producing end that
says like, hey, I'm gonna consume this stream
and I'm gonna convert it to the older
version and publish that as well.
And so a mechanism like that gives other
parties a
lenience period where they can still rely on
the old information stream, but then also have
at their disposal
an opt event
stream, which they can consume in parallel
and then try it out for a bit
and then convert all of their integrations
without needing to do it as as a
hard cut. Can I just confirm something there?
Because that was really really interesting to me
personally. Right? Because versioning is hard.
And when we talk about challenges of this,
I'm sure versioning is gonna be one of
the biggest ones. So maybe we'll come back
to it. But
I never really thought of it publishing or
having a producer who already has all the
knowledge of the versions. Right? Because it's their
domain.
Do you publish them as separate events with
the different versions or do you, like, wrap
them in an envelope and publish them as
one event with multiple versions as a payload?
Like, how how does that work in practice?
In practice, it's so if you need to
couple them in the same message,
they needed to be produced atomically.
Right? So thinking of this a little bit
longer, I think you you can do it
like that even if the producer doesn't produce
them both versions.
But what would the benefit be? Well, I
was thinking if the producer emits version three
of an event Yeah. Has a function to
downcast it to v one and v two,
wraps them in an envelope and publishes it,
then the consumers can kinda cherry pick out
the version that they understand
the most or the latest version that they
Yeah. React to and and handle it. But
then, I guess, you you she also went
downstream to be working through the latest version
too. Yeah. Yeah. Tough problem. So that is
possible.
You would be publishing
multiple versions
of the same event inside
of the same event stream. Right? So what
you sometimes have is that upgrading
event versions or entire streams, they're used as
an opportunity also to reprovision
all of the infrastructure
that's behind it. So if you need more
topics on your Kafka stream, right, having a
new stream
is sort of an opportunity to say like,
hey, I'm gonna over provision a little bit
again. So I've got some breathing room for
my concurrency,
for my consumers.
So usually you want to have that as
a possibility.
And now a consumer will rarely
in one business process consume multiple
versions of the same events. Right? So usually
what
you do as a consumer is you're gonna
put side by side multiple consumers that do
version a and version b side by side
and then you can sort of compute. Like
if you want to do a parallel run
and you can check for for differences afterwards.
So they just have one thing. So you
you can you can certainly do it. I've
never seen it being done like that. So
usually what you what you see and what
I think is idiomatic in that space is
that you have either on the same stream,
you have that payloads
of multiple
versions. So you have a type and a
version of the type and it's published over
the same stream.
Or if the entire stream is being upgraded
from one version to another, which is usually
the case if the structure of the data
or the payloads are fundamentally changing.
So either there's something changing in the envelope,
that's usually a case where everything got bumps
up one version.
Then you see more often that an entire
new stream of events is being introduced for
those games. Nice.
Well, it feels only fitting that we're talking
about some of the hard stuff then with
event sourcing that we maybe see. Are there
any other challenges that you've faced adopting event
sourcing as capital and other places that you
wanna share with people like, you know, assuming
some masochist listening to this podcast is when,
you know what? This sounds really cool.
Hard, but really, really cool. Like, what else
should they be looking at for? What else
have you worked through?
Yeah. So one of the areas where it's
both a virtue and a and a curse
to have event driven architectures
in place
is disaster recovery.
So as soon as sort of metaphorical ship
hits the fan and maybe you have catastrophic
infrastructure
failure and the consuming system
loses all of their state, they need to
rebuild that state from somewhere. So in more
state based systems,
you either work off of maybe a database
replica or something else. You sort of like
ingest or restart that whole replication process
with database native technologies. You're in in place
relatively
relatively quick.
For event driven architectures,
it can be more cumbersome and you need
to design for it. So for example, if
you need to if you've got a projection
and you need to recreate all of your
current state based on everything that's been recorded
before,
the question is always like, how far back
do you need to go in order to
figure out what to reconstitute from?
Are you gonna do that from the epoch
of your business, right, from day one of
your business? Or are you gonna have some
intermittent states where you're gonna say, like, alright,
I've got a snapshot of the of the
state that it was at, and now I'm
gonna reconstitute
from from that point and out and reconsume.
Now that is not something that is very
trivial to design for. And you need to
apply a couple of sort of supporting practices
which help you,
to do that. I think Kafka as a
technology
makes it easier to do some of those
things mostly because they have a incremental offset
based storage strategy where you know where you
left off and if you have a snapshot
that's at a particular Kafka
partition
combination,
you can take that state and know, alright,
I'm I was exactly there and I can
go on and reconsume
the rest. If you don't have such a
system and you have got your own sort
of like delivery mechanism, if you're going through
RabbitMQ
or any type of other like sort of
transient message
queue implementation,
Right? You need a way to inform the
producer of those events to re flush whatever
they had. So reconstitution
of
these
read models becomes a lot more involved.
So it's it's not all cherries and rainbows
in that sense. One of the things that
you can actually do is use your partitioning
strategy
and your log compaction strategy on Kafka
to always ensure that all of the leave
notes,
retain the latest bit of information. And if
that fits your domain model, then you can
use that as a way to quickly get
to the latest state of everything. Because effectively
on all of those partitions,
you guarantee with like every key,
the last message of that key contains
the last state that I'm interested in in
order to get to the to the current
state. But that's very much like in the
details of of your implementation already. So there
are opportunities there, but you really need to
understand whether those solutions really match the problem
space where you're applying it. And that's not
always the case. Awesome.
Alright. I'm not sure how many people still
wanna build events or systems after hearing that,
but
it definitely is. It's fun. At least you're
Well, so sometimes you don't have a choice.
Right? So for example, if you have a
source system which is unreliable
and you have a high value system that's
dependent on it, right, are you gonna accept
the downtime of this system as a limiter
for your value creation stream? Like, no. Right?
So you want to be kept up to
date with the with the latest information.
So, yeah, you're gonna swallow some of those
costs and, and difficulties
that are associated with event driven architectures.
Usually, you're just trading one bag of problems
for another where you hope that the the
downsides of those problems
will affect you less and that the upsides
of having done that will reap you more
benefits. Exactly. The the classic answer, it depends.
Right? Like, you got you got to pick
your trade offs. You got to pick
which level of complexity you need for your
application. And event sourcing has a very
interesting
and applicable and useful and value add and
some domains that you really need to go
down the rabbit hole.
But definitely not all. Yeah.
Alright. Well, I'm curious then.
What are you excited about these days? What
new shiny things are you playing with, experiment,
whatever, even just interested in you've not attempted
to play with yet? Like, what what's in
the future for Frank? So I'm I'm curious
to see if we like, on the sort
of real time aspect of ingesting data, there
is a lot of, like, experience that I
have on implementing that. The one area where
I have lots less
experience is on the sort of on the
controlling side of it. Right? So real time
interactions
with with system,
systems which can also be message based from
so imagine
you have a react UI and that's a
that's not a blog or another type of
sort of simple information system, but more like
a system that you really interact with hands
on to see like, hey, how can you
interact with that system in real time and
then get real time responses out.
So I know that PHP is not really
a language where that's super easy to do
In the sort of TypeScript node worlds, there's
definitely
some precedence for that. And in the Java,
like JVM ecosystem,
there's also a bit of that. But I
also want to learn more about Rust, so
maybe I will just use Rust as my
next language to experiment with and implement that.
So, yeah,
that's a general area, but it's still really
fuzzy for me
in terms of like, hey, what does that
really look like and what type of
systems can I study in order to learn
more about it? Sweet. Alright. Well, I'm looking
forward to seeing Event Source and Rust then.
I think that's gonna be a
lot of fun for you to watch. I'm
I'm I'm guessing it should probably like if
I'm looking at Rust, it probably involves some
kind of macros.
So
I mean, you could write some really sweet
procedural macros in Rust to handle the replay
logic within
structs. I think that would be super cool,
and everything would work within an implementation block.
I think the developer experience and the API
you could provide for event sourcing in Rust
would far surpass any other language. Alright. Because
as really great macro support. Metaprogramming in Rust
is good. Metaprogramming in Go Not so good.
So much. No.
No. Like, in in Go, there are some
awkward bits if you need to do event
sourcing
there because, like, it's very difficult to do
anything very dynamic and
event stuff is usually usually benefits from some
dynamic forms of programming. We'll we'll go to
that generic support in one
eighteen or one nineteen. So I think that
landscape is now wide open for some innovation,
but certainly prior to that, it it's been
tedious at best. So
this has been awesome. Thank you so much
for spending the last hour of your life
sharing your event sourcing journey with me and
lots of interesting information for people listening at
home. And then I'll give you just a
minute and say you wanna share your Twitter
handle, plug your website, your company, open source
projects, now would be the time to to
plug away. Cool.
So if you have any file system needs
within the PHP ecosystem,
check out Flysystem,
which is the main PHP file system abstraction
library.
If you need to build anything event sourced
also in PHP, check out EventSauce
or check out EventSauce.io.
Check out my employer. They're called Personio. If
you're
a company that needs to
work with HR processes or any other type
of HR tooling, that's what they provide. So
do check them out.
And when I have the time, I blog
on my personal website,
which is blog @frankdejonga.nl.
Alright. Thank you very much.